we have a great show tonight a terrific
show I'm sorry does anyone else smell
that it smells like room-temperature
gravy in here do you smell that Andy no
no I don't uh I probably somebody left a
meatloaf and one of the heating ducts or
something nope who would leave meatloaf
in the heating duct no would do that and
what's going on with your lectern what
do you mean what do I mean it looks like
your lecterns made out of wet beef oh
yeah well you know how sometimes I'll
race out of here after the show and
drive all night straight to the first
casino of the Nevada border and then
I'll put on my lucky sweatpants the ones
that say juicy on the back and play keno
until my cash and credit all run out and
you know how then when I'm broke I'll
sometimes go over to where the seniors
are playing slots look for the most
frail of the bunch and stand on their
oxygen hose until they hand over their
plastic bucket full of nickels and then
I'll lose all of that too you know and
I'll hitch a ride on a poultry truck and
arrive just in time for the next day's
rehearsal you know how I sometimes do
that no no I didn't know any of that
right because it's none of your business
Andy what does any of that have to do
with your lectern being made of meat
well long story short I owe a lot of
money to a lot of people so I decided
one way I could get some extra cash is
by getting sponsorship for my lectern
and this week the fine people at good
doggie brand dog food came through and
if you don't mind I'd love to say a few
words about my new sponsor you know it's
cool but I'd rather we didn't do that
but I think we should do is this when
you have a dog you love
you want only the best nutrition for him
but what about if your dog is only okay
maybe he's bitten a couple of kids or it
was your boyfriend's dog and you're more
of a cat person does that dog really
deserve the best or does he deserve good
dog good doggy is made from 100% legal
meat byproducts and it's prisoner tested
so if you've got a good dog but not a
great dog
get him good doggie dog he won't care
oh you're just gonna you're just gonna
spend the show standing behind a pile of
wet dog food is that what you're gonna
do
that's not so bad only downside is it
does attract stray dogs and and
prisoners yeah I got it all right 20 way
we have a fine show tonight from the new
FX series trust two-time Academy
he's in the audience
there's a dog in the audience yes
there's a dog kept hearing the idea of
this escape he's fine okay all right
well okay I guess you get to keep them
yeah yeah I bet Ellen doesn't have a dog
we have we have the most unprofessional
show on television
you